In a way, the story is always the same-- There was this kid. She was mean. She was popular. It's such a fixture of childhood, you can just walk up to a kid on the sidewalk or at a public pool, and they'll tell you.
从某种程度上讲，故事总是大同小异——曾经有个孩子，她很刻薄，也很受欢迎。这在童年时期是如此普遍，你随便在人行道上或公共泳池找个孩子，他们都能告诉你。
The popularest is this girl. She's in my grade. She's really mean. And she has a lot of friends. I wanted to play with her, and then she had no friends, so she said, yeah. The other day, I wanted to play with her again, and her friends were there, and she said, get lost.
最受欢迎的是这个女孩，跟我同一年级。她真的很刻薄，但有很多朋友。我本来想跟她一起玩，后来她没朋友了，就答应了。那天，我又想跟她玩，但她的朋友们都在，她说：“走开。”
Sometimes she-- she be being mean to my sister, and I don't like that. She always telling somebody what they can and can't do. She act like she the boss of people. She real bossy.
有时候她会对我妹妹刻薄，我不喜欢那样。她总是告诉别人什么能做，什么不能做。她表现得好像是大家的老大一样，真的很霸道。
She thinks she got the rhythm and the gear.
她以为她很有节奏感，也很有范儿。
I'm mostly the popular one in my class, but I have a lot of other popular friends. This boy in my class, he liked me. And every time he would come by me, I would tell him to get out of my way. Everybody says that he's the nerdiest boy in our class. He'll start bothering me and my friends, and I'll tell him to leave us alone. My friends even tell him, don't even look at her. [LAUGHS]
我在班里算是受欢迎的那类人，但我还有很多受欢迎的朋友。班上有个男生喜欢我，每次他靠近我，我都会叫他离我远点。大家都说他是班里最书呆子的男生。他开始烦我和我的朋友们，我就会叫他别来打扰我们。我的朋友们甚至会对他说：“看都别看她一眼。”[笑声]
I talked to a high school sophomore about all this, Lillie Allison, 15, in Woods Hole, Massachusetts. And she said, in high school, anyway, it's kind of like the laws of nature. Someone always will end up on top.
我跟一位来自马萨诸塞州伍兹霍尔的15岁高二学生莉莉·艾利森聊了聊这件事。她说，在高中的话，这就像自然法则，总有人会最终站在顶端。
Because there's always going to be the girls who are the most popular, that the guys look at the most and that get the friends because they're so pretty. There's always going to be those girls.
因为总会有那种最受欢迎的女孩，她们最受男生关注，也因为长得漂亮而拥有很多朋友。总是会有这样的女孩。
Hmm.
嗯。
And I think once people get the idea that they have that power, they're going to use it. And they know that they can be mean to people and still be loved by everyone. You have nothing to lose, so why don't you go ahead and be mean to everybody that's not as good as you?
我想一旦人们意识到自己拥有那种权力，他们就会利用它。他们知道即使对别人刻薄，依然会受到大家的喜爱。你没什么可失去的，所以为什么不顺便对那些不如你的人刻薄一点呢？
In Lillie's class, the girls like that, the popular ones, had been her best friends.
在莉莉的班上，那种女孩——那些受欢迎的女孩——曾经是她最好的朋友。
When I became friends with them, it was in seventh grade, and there was none of that. It was before the superlatives and before there was a most attractive.
我刚和她们成为朋友时是在七年级，那时还没有这些东西。是在排位次和评选“最有魅力”之前。
Right.
没错。
And I'll admit, I was one of those girls until the first time they kicked me out of their little group. And then I saw how it really is. That's what we were. We were the Four Blondes.
我也承认，在她们第一次把我踢出小团体之前，我也是那种女孩之一。后来我才看清真相。我们当时就是那样，我们是“四个金发女郎”。
And what was it like to be one of those girls?
成为其中一员是什么感觉？
It was fun, you know? I mean, the attention is kind of fun. Look at them looking at us. And it's fun. It makes you feel powerful. I mean, part of being one of the Four Blondes is that everybody does the same thing, shaves their legs every day, has a perfect matching outfit. You know what I mean?
很有趣，你知道吗？那种被关注的感觉挺有趣的。看着别人注视我们，这种感觉很有趣，让你觉得自己很有权势。毕竟，作为“四个金发女郎”之一，大家都要做同样的事：每天刮腿毛，穿一模一样的完美套装。你懂我意思吗？
Yeah.
懂。
Makeup always has to be perfect-- not too much, not too little. Suck up to the teachers. Like, I remember I went two weeks without wearing a skirt, and one of them called me and was like, you have to wear a skirt tomorrow. You've worn pants too many days in a row. And if you don't fit that, then you get kicked out for a little while.
妆容必须永远完美——不多不少。要拍老师马屁。我记得有两周我没穿裙子，其中一个人打电话跟我说：“明天你必须穿裙子。你已经连续好几天穿裤子了。”如果你不符合要求，就会被踢出去一段时间。
Lillie got kicked out at the beginning of the summer. She made a mistake. She didn't do what the other girls wanted at some party. So they called her up to kick her out.
莉莉是在夏天开始的时候被踢出去的。她犯了个错，在某个派对上没有按其他女孩的要求做。于是她们打电话叫她过去，然后把她踢了。
One of them is like-- she's the mean one. It's kind of like the Spice Girls. We all have our own little identity. You know what I mean?
其中一个就是——她是那个“刻薄担当”。就像辣妹组合一样，我们每个人都有自己的身份定位。你懂我意思吧？
Yeah.
懂。
There was the tough one, the cute one, the smart one. You know what I mean?
有“强悍担当”、“可爱担当”、“聪明担当”，你明白吧？
And the mean one.
还有“刻薄担当”。
Yeah. And so when we all got in this fight, they called me up, and they put the mean one on the phone. They'd tell her what to say. She'd say it to me, then put me on hold, figure out what else they wanted her to say, and then say it.
对。所以当我们吵架时，她们给我打电话，让那个“刻薄担当”和我通电话。她们会告诉她该说什么，她说完后就把我晾在一边，商量好还要让我说什么，然后再继续。
Wait. They put you on hold, so you just sit there and hold, waiting for them to come up with the next mean thing?
等等。她们把你晾在一边（hold），你就坐在那儿等着她们想出下一句刻薄的话？
That's right. And they didn't even realize how mean it was.
没错。而且她们甚至没意识到这有多刻薄。
Of course it doesn't always end in high school. And this isn't just about teenage girls. There are popular bullies in business and in politics-- and very successful ones in politics. Our movies and TV shows are full of them. There's an entire industry of gangster rap. Today on our show, the allure of the mean friend and what is so alluring about them in the first place, explained. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in four acts.
当然，这种情况并不总是在高中结束。这也不仅仅是关于少女的问题。在商业和政治领域也存在这种受欢迎的霸凌者，而且在政治上还非常成功。我们的电影和电视剧里到处都是他们。甚至有一个庞大的匪帮说唱产业。今天我们的节目将探讨“刻薄朋友”的魅力，以及究竟是什么让她们显得如此有吸引力。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为四个篇章。
Act One, Return to the Scene of the Crime. In that act, Jonathan Goldstein interrogates the girls, now grown up, who terrorized him and his classmates years ago in school, and finds that they can be just as scary as ever. Act Two, Does Niceness Pay? In that act, we conduct a little scientific experiment on tape, with hidden microphones, about whether niceness can triumph and be rewarded in a normal business setting, a setting that will surely be familiar to you.
第一篇章：重返犯罪现场。在这一章里，乔纳森·戈尔茨坦盘问了那些当年在学校里恐吓他和同学们、现在已经长大的女孩，发现她们依然让人感到恐惧。第二篇章：友善会有回报吗？在这一章中，我们用隐藏麦克风进行了一次小小的科学实验，看看在普通的商业环境中，友善是否能胜出并得到回报，这种环境想必你们都很熟悉。
Act Three, And What's Going On With You? A case study in every word out of a friend's mouth meaning its exact opposite. Act Four, Keeping it in the Family. In that act, Bernard Cooper's amazing story about the bill that he got from his own father for, well, the entire cost of his childhood. Stay with us.
第三篇章：你最近怎么样？一个案例研究，探讨朋友口中的每一句话都是反话。第四篇章：家务事。在这一章中，伯纳德·库珀讲述了一个惊人的故事：他父亲给他开了一张账单，列出了他童年的全部花费。请继续收听。
Act One, Return to the Scene of the Crime. It wasn't hard for Jonathan Goldstein to find the girl who terrorized him in high school. Up until a year ago, they were roommates.
第一篇章：重返犯罪现场。乔纳森·戈尔茨坦找到那个在高中恐吓他的女孩并不难。直到一年前，他们还是室友。
Sometimes, when I'm talking with my friend Jackie Cohen, I will suddenly stop and just look at her. I look at her as though I have only just then realized who it is I am sitting there talking with. Jackie Cohen, I will say, shaking my head in disbelief. Jackie Cohen.
有时候，当我和朋友杰基·科恩交谈时，我会突然停下来看着她。我看着她，仿佛才刚刚意识到坐在我对面说话的人是谁。“杰基·科恩，”我会难以置信地摇头说道，“杰基·科恩。”
For you see, Jackie Cohen was the meanest, most popular girl in our junior high, a shepherd among sheep. Nowadays, Jackie Cohen and I are friends, good friends. In fact, for two years, we were roommates, during which time she was a very nurturing figure in my life, cooking for me, taking care of the bills, and doing most, if not all, of the cleaning. My domestic role was confined to stuff like drinking Jim Beam and keeping her up past her bedtime with my impression of Robert De Niro and Edith Bunker doing the lobster scene from Annie Hall. "Alvy, a lobster crawled into my purse."
要知道，杰基·科恩曾经是我们初中最刻薄、最受欢迎的女孩，羊群中的领头羊。如今，我和杰基·科恩是好朋友。事实上，我们当过两年的室友，那段时间里，她在我生活中一直是个非常照顾我的人：为我做饭、处理账单，并且承担了大部分（如果不是全部）清洁工作。我的家务角色仅限于喝吉姆·比姆威士忌，用我模仿罗伯特·德尼罗和伊迪丝·邦克在《安妮·霍尔》中饰演龙虾场景的表演让她熬夜。“阿尔维，一只龙虾爬进了我的钱包。”
Just the same, sometimes when I feel like it, I can see her through the eyes of my grade 7 self. And when I do that and say the words "Jackie Cohen," it is as though it is no longer just the name of the woman before me, but a name for something famous, like a soft drink or a rock band. If I could go back in time and tell the young Jonathan Goldstein that one day he would be friends with the most popular girl at Western Laval Junior High, that young Jonathan Goldstein, taking in the utter absurdity of such a proposition, would laugh convulsively until his nose produced mucus and his eyeglasses needed adjusting.
尽管如此，有时当我兴致来了，我依然能通过七年级自己的眼睛看着她。当我那样做并说出“杰基·科恩”这个名字时，它仿佛不再只是面前那个女人的名字，而是一个著名事物的代称，就像一种饮料或一个摇滚乐队的名字。如果我能回到过去告诉年轻的乔纳森·戈尔茨坦，有一天你会和西方拉瓦尔初中最受欢迎的女孩成为朋友，那个年轻的乔纳森·戈尔茨坦在体会到这种说法的荒谬后，一定会笑得抽搐，直到鼻子里流出粘液，眼镜都需要调整。
Let me explain to you the power that was Jackie Cohen's. So great was her authority that in grade 7, my best friend, Robert Ceolic, wore a three-piece suit to school with the intention of asking her out for souvlaki. I'll never forget the exhilarated look on his face as he ran back to our locker bank to tell me that, while Jackie Cohen had turned him down, she did say that they could be "hi, bye" friends. This meant that when they saw each other in the halls, they could nod to each other, hi and bye. Robert loosened his necktie like a middle-aged ad exec who had just closed an important account.
让我给你们解释一下杰基·科恩当年的威力。她的权威之大，以至于在七年级时，我最好的朋友罗伯特·塞奥利克穿着三件套西装去学校，打算约她去吃希腊烤肉。我永远不会忘记他跑回储物柜边时脸上那兴奋的神情，他告诉我，虽然杰基·科恩拒绝了他，但她说他们可以做“嗨，拜”朋友。这意味着当他们在走廊相遇时，可以点头打招呼，说声“嗨”或“拜”。罗伯特松了松领带，就像一个刚签下重要大单的中年广告主管一样。
Another thing was that Jackie Cohen didn't like bad smells. She liked nice smells, like perfumed fancy erasers or freshly mimeographed sheets of paper. So if someone's smell was not to her taste, she would leave a note on their desk. The note would read, "You smell. Use deodorant." Jackie Cohen would call it being honest.
还有一件事是，杰基·科恩讨厌难闻的气味。她喜欢好闻的气味，比如香喷喷的花式橡皮擦或刚油印出来的纸张。所以如果谁身上的味道不合她的心意，她就会在他们的课桌上留一张纸条。纸条上写着：“你身上有味，用点除臭剂。”杰基·科恩管这叫“诚实”。
Jackie Cohen was also the only 13-year-old girl in school who could actually pull off a successful withering look. There was a month where I sat behind her, and one time during a French dictation, I was seized with an uncontrollable attack of coughing. It would later be diagnosed as a whooping cough that would leave me in bed for a week with a fever of 103.
杰基·科恩也是学校里唯一一个13岁就能做出成功鄙夷眼神的女孩。有一个月我坐在她身后，有一次在法语听写课上，我被一阵无法控制的咳嗽发作困扰。后来被诊断为百日咳，让我卧床一周，高烧103度。
But at that moment, it was nothing more, nothing less, than a nuisance to Jackie. She let me know this by whipping her head around, her straight brown hair lashing about like a thousand throwing stars, and witheringly looking me straight in the eye. Jackie turned back around, and I grit my teeth, vowing not to allow a single cough to escape my mouth. My eyes tearing, I clenched my fists, and I trembled. I knew, objectively speaking, that Jackie Cohen's [NON-ENGLISH] was more important than my own health. I knew that.
但在那一刻，在杰基看来，这不过是个麻烦。她转过头，顺滑的棕色头发像上千颗飞镖一样甩过，用鄙夷的眼神直视着我的眼睛，以此让我明白这一点。杰基转过身去，我咬紧牙关，发誓不让哪怕一声咳嗽逃出喉咙。我眼含热泪，攥紧拳头，浑身颤抖。我知道，客观地说，杰基·科恩的[非英语词]比我自己的健康更重要。我深知这一点。
The teacher, finally seeing my condition, sent me out to get some water. At the fountain, just as I was about to drink, my knees buckled, and I began to throw up. I wasn't the kind of kid who vomited much, and the experience felt very personal, sort of like crying in your underwear. The special ed teacher in the room next to the bathroom came out and walked me back to my class.
老师最终看到了我的状况，让我出去喝点水。在饮水机旁，就在我准备喝水时，我的膝盖一软，开始呕吐。我不是那种经常呕吐的孩子，这种经历感觉非常私密，就像穿着内裤哭泣一样。隔壁教室的一位特殊教育老师走出来，把我送回了教室。
Jackie, who sat beside the door, as was the wanton responsibility of the most popular, let me in. Seeing me, she gave me this look-- not the withering look I had grown accustomed to, but another look, a look then, until then, I'd only seen on the face of adults. It was a look of profound pity. I saw in that look a sorrow for everything she had ever put me through, and for years, I held that look close to my heart.
坐在门边的杰基，作为最受欢迎的学生，顺理成章地负责让我进去。看到我时，她给了我一个眼神——不是我习惯的那种鄙夷眼神，而是另一个眼神，一个直到那时我只在成年人脸上见过的眼神。那是一种深切同情的眼神。我在那个眼神里看到了她对我曾经施加的所有折磨的歉意，多年来，我一直把那个眼神珍藏在心里。
Jackie had really good hair.
杰基的发质真的很好。
This is Marie-Claude. She was Jackie's best friend all through school, and they're still best friends now.
这是玛丽-克劳德。她是杰基整个学生时代最好的朋友，现在她们依然是闺蜜。
Very good hair. Nicely layered, kind of feathered. And she had a special technique. Well, first of all, she always walked around with a comb in her back pocket that stuck out for all to see. And we'd go to the bathroom. A big part of the day, of course, was going to the bathroom. And she had a special technique. She'd bend her head over. She'd count 1, 2, 3, and then take her two index fingers and say, flip, and flip her hair back. And then it would fall. The feathers would all fall beautifully in place.
发质非常好。层次感很好，有点羽毛剪。她还有个特殊的技巧。首先，她总是随身带着一把梳子插在后口袋里，好让所有人都能看见。我们会去洗手间，当然，那一天的很大一部分时间就是去洗手间。她有个特殊技巧：低下头，数一、二、三，然后用两个食指说：“翻”，把头发甩回去。接着，头发就会落下，羽毛般的发丝就会完美地各就各位。
What was Jackie Cohen's allure? Did people like her despite the fact that she was mean? Or did they like her because she was so mean?
杰基·科恩的魅力到底是什么？人们喜欢她是因为她哪怕很刻薄也很有吸引力吗？还是因为她太刻薄了所以大家才喜欢她？
I think it was a bit of both. Because when you were with her, you felt really alive. And she was so fun, and she was so full of life, so it was great being with her. But then before you knew it, you were on the outs. She was looking for a certain quality, and if you didn't have it, you got kicked out. So it was also maybe the fun excitement of never knowing when your turn was going to come to be on the outs. And you were always trying to do your best to stay on the inside. So it was pretty exciting.
我觉得两者皆有。因为当你在她身边时，你会感觉自己真的活过来了。她很有趣，充满活力，所以和她在一起很棒。但还没等你反应过来，你就被淘汰了。她在寻找某种特质，如果你没有，你就被踢出局了。所以，那种永远不知道何时轮到自己被踢出去的刺激感也很有趣。你总是努力表现最好，以留在圈子里。所以那真的很让人兴奋。
Did she ever-- I mean, did my name ever come up in junior high? Did she ever mention my name?
她有没有……我是说，在初中时我的名字有没有出现过？她提起过我的名字吗？
Oh, yeah. I remember a time. You were new to school. You were the new kid, and I wanted to go over to talk to you. And Jackie said, no, don't go talk to him, Marie. Don't talk to him. He looks dirty.
噢，有。我记得有一次，你刚转学过来，你是新来的，我本想过去和你说话。杰基说：“不，别过去跟他说话，玛丽。别跟他说话。他看起来脏兮兮的。”
She thought I looked dirty?
她觉得我看起来脏兮兮的？
Yeah, she did.
对，她确实这么觉得。
That was how my name came up?
这就是我名字被提起的原因？
Yeah, that you looked dirty. You were the dirty-looking new kid.
对，说你看起来很脏。你是那个看起来脏脏的新生。
OK, first of all, the new kid. The party Marie-Claude is referring to is in grade 6. I had been going to that school since grade 3. I was in the same school as them, evidently completely unnoticed, for three years-- and second of all, dirty. Although my boyhood toilette was second to none, and although I was facially hairless, for some strange reason, I gave off the distinct impression of having a 5 o'clock shadow all over my body. So I decided to confront the slanderous accusations at their source. Ladies and gentlemen, Jackie Cohen.
好了，首先，“新生”？玛丽-克劳德提到的这件事发生在六年级。我从三年级开始就在那所学校了，显然在她们眼里完全是个透明人，整整三年——其次，“脏”？虽然我的男孩卫生习惯无人能及，虽然我还没长胡子，但出于某种奇怪的原因，我全身总是散发着一种像是没刮胡子的印象。所以我决定直接向这毁谤的源头对质。女士们，先生们，杰基·科恩。
Jackie Cohen.
杰基·科恩。
Jon, please don't tell me the whole interview is going to be like this.
乔，请别告诉我整个采访都要这样。
I asked Jackie Cohen if she remembered calling me dirty and new to Marie-Claude, and she said she did. I then asked her to repeat the very line to me, right to my face.
我问杰基·科恩是否记得对玛丽-克劳德说我很脏、是个新生，她说她记得。然后我让她当面把那句话重复给我听。
You know what I said.
你知道我说过什么的。
Come on.
别这样。
Why don't you say it?
为什么你不说出来？
All right. I will.
好吧，我说。
All right, fine.
行吧，好吧。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You said, don't talk to him because he's dirty.
你说的是：“别跟他说话，因为他很脏。”
Yeah. Yeah.
没错。对。
Well, maybe I was dirty.
嗯，也许我当时真的很脏。
You were. And you still are.
你确实很脏。而且现在依然很脏。
Jackie Cohen and I spent a very combative hour talking, during which time she would not admit to any actual meanness. The furthest she would go in making any kind of concession was in acknowledging that back then, she, quote, "took care of business"-- a whole lot of business.
杰基·科恩和我就这样进行了一场火药味十足的对话，期间她拒不承认任何真实的刻薄行为。她所能做出的最大让步只是承认当时她“处理了一些事情”——处理了一大堆事情。
Listen, no one's on trial, OK? We're here, just two friends chatting.
听着，没人受审，好吗？我们就在这儿，两个朋友聊天而已。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
No, Jackie Cohen did not think she was mean in school. Take the whole story of Robert Ceolic asking her out in junior high. You know, Mr. Hi, Bye. And she stood firmly behind her actions.
不，杰基·科恩并不认为她在学校里很刻薄。拿罗伯特·塞奥利克在初中约她的整件事来说，也就是“嗨，拜先生”。她坚定地为自己的行为辩护。
Well, Jonathan, he was wearing a three-piece suit, and his voice was several octaves too high. What am I going to say to the guy? Yes? And-- and not only did I tell him no, but I left him with his dignity. I actually had him thinking that we had a good thing going. We were going to be "hi, bye" friends.
好吧，乔纳森，他当时穿着三件套西装，嗓音比正常高了八度。你让我对他说什么？答应？我不仅拒绝了他，还给了他尊严。我甚至让他以为我们之间有什么好发展的。我们要成为“嗨，拜”朋友。
So what you're saying is that-- you're defending it. You're saying it was actually-- it's a nice thing that you did.
所以你的意思是……你在为自己辩护。你在说你做的其实是一件好事？
It was very nice. Wasn't he very happy when he came into the room?
那是很友好的。他走进教室的时候不也很开心吗？
He was happy, but I mean, he didn't know any better.
他当时是很开心，但我意思是，他根本不知道真相。
Exactly. You want me to go on a date with that guy?
没错。你难道想让我跟那个家伙约会吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Feel the way that laugh shivers you down to your toes? The way it taunts as it entices? That is the effect of a popular mean girl's laughter. The truth is that Jackie Cohen is no longer a popular mean girl at all. She's actually a doctor who works with the homeless. She's a really good person. But I still can't help relating to her as though the old Jackie Cohen is still somewhere buried inside of her.
感受到那种让你寒毛直竖的笑声了吗？那种既嘲弄又诱惑的感觉？那就是受欢迎的刻薄女孩笑声的效果。事实是，杰基·科恩早已不再是那个受欢迎的刻薄女孩了。她现在是一位致力于救助无家可归者的医生。她是个真正的好人。但我依然忍不住把她和旧时杰基·科恩联系在一起，好像那个旧的杰基依然埋藏在她内心深处。
Let me ask you this. What happens to the mean girl?
让我问你个问题。那个刻薄女孩后来怎么了？
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Is the mean always there?
刻薄依然存在吗？
Jon, these questions are boring, man. [LAUGHS]
乔，这些问题很无聊，老兄。[笑声]
Oh, you don't like that one. That's OK. OK. OK, let's do a little bit of role-playing, shall we? OK? You're going to be the grade 8 Jackie Cohen, and I'm going to be the grade 8 Jonathan Goldstein, OK? And I'm in the Western Laval Junior High Radio Club.
噢，你不喜欢这个问题。没关系。好吧，咱们玩个角色扮演，好吗？你是八年级的杰基·科恩，我是八年级的乔纳森·戈尔茨坦，好吗？我在西方拉瓦尔初中广播社。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And I'm sitting down to interview you. All right? OK, here we go.
我在采访你。好吗？我们开始吧。
[LAUGHS] OK, yeah.
[笑声] 好，行。
Um, Jackie?
呃，杰基？
Yeah?
什么？
Can I have a bit of your time to interview you?
我能占用你一点时间接受采访吗？
No.
不能。
Why?
为什么？
I'm busy.
我很忙。
But you're just--
但你只是……
But thank you.
但还是谢谢你。
But you're just leaning against the locker. You're not--
但你只是靠在储物柜边。你没……
But thank you, Jonathan. I'm really not interested.
但谢谢你，乔纳森。我真的没兴趣。
No, you see, you wouldn't even be that polite.
不，你看，你连这样礼貌都不会有。
You're right. Honestly, I would have laughed and walked away.
你说得对。说实话，我当时会笑一笑然后走开。
You see, this was the Jackie Cohen that I never got to talk to anymore. She's never like this. I mean, sure, she's always eager to let me know when someone in the room smells better than me, and she's quick to point out that my pasty white gut jiggles when I play air guitar. But it always feels like a mere taste of the greatness that once was. So we continued to parry and thrust our way along.
看到了吧，这就是我再也无法交谈的杰基·科恩。她从来不会这样。当然，她总是急于让我知道房间里谁闻起来比我香，她也很快会指出我弹空气吉他时苍白的肚子在抖动。但这感觉只是当年那种伟大的冰山一角。所以我们继续推拉着。
Is this over yet?
还没结束吗？
And eventually, the subject came around to Jackie's older sister, Maureen. Now, let me just explain to you Maureen. As mean and popular as Jackie Cohen was, Maureen Cohen was more mean and more popular.
最终，话题转到了杰基的姐姐莫琳身上。现在，让我给你解释一下莫琳。和杰基·科恩一样刻薄且受欢迎，但莫琳·科恩更刻薄、更受欢迎。
Well, my sister definitely taught me some of the tricks of the trade by being very, very, very cruel with me and very bossy and very demanding. She would say that, really, she was doing me a big favor, because without her, I would never have made it in this world, that I was just such a boring, nice little kid. And she added a lot of spice to my life.
嗯，我姐姐确实教了我一些生存技巧，她对我非常、非常、非常残忍，而且非常霸道、非常苛刻。她会说，她其实是在帮我大忙，因为没有她，我永远无法在这个世界上生存，说我只是个无聊、乖巧的小孩。她让我的生活增添了很多色彩。
In the pursuit of my mean, popular girls scholarship, I knew I now had to talk with Maureen. I was not in the same city as her, so I asked my friend Joshua Carpatty if he would be good enough to go to her house and hold a mic to her while we talked on the phone. Josh has been scared of Maureen for years, and here he was sitting with her in her living room, while her seven-year-old played on the floor at their feet.
为了完成我的“刻薄女孩研究”，我知道我现在必须和莫琳谈谈。我当时不在她所在的城市，所以我请朋友约书亚·卡帕蒂帮我个忙，去她家在她和我通话时举着麦克风。乔什多年来一直很怕莫琳，此时他正坐在她客厅里，而她7岁的孩子在地板上玩耍。
As Maureen provided a rare behind-the-scenes glimpse of her thoughts and actions, Josh sat just a few inches from her, a microphone gripped in his sweaty, nervous hand. And as I talked with her, Maureen acknowledged that she had been mean in high school. She made no bones about it. And to her, there was nothing to regret. It was high school, and that's just how people acted.
当莫琳罕见地展示了她背后的思维和行为时，乔什就坐在她几英寸外，手里握着那个满是汗水的麦克风。我和她交谈时，莫琳承认她高中时确实很刻薄。她毫不掩饰。对她来说，没什么好后悔的。那是高中，大家都是那样表现的。
So what, you have this image of me of being really mean all the time?
所以呢，你有那种我一直都很刻薄的印象？
But in an alluring way. You know what I mean? People crave it somehow. Obviously, it works.
但那种刻薄很有吸引力。你懂我意思吗？人们不知为何渴望这种感觉。显而易见，这很奏效。
Well, some people like to be abused. And you just tap into it, you know?
嗯，有些人喜欢被虐待。而你刚好顺应了这种需求，你知道吗？
Right. And then you satisfy that craving that they're not even entirely aware of.
对。然后你满足了那种他们甚至没有完全察觉到的需求。
That's right.
没错。
Well, how do you detect that?
你是怎么察觉到的？
I don't know. You talk to someone, and you just feel whether or not you can play with them or not. Like, I think Josh loves the fact that I pay that kind of attention to him.
我不知道。你和某人交谈，就能感觉到是否能玩弄他们。比如，我觉得乔什很喜欢我对他那种关注方式。
Josh, the young man who's holding the microphone for you right now?
乔什，那个现在正为你举着麦克风的年轻人？
Yeah, who's so scared, he won't even look at me.
对，他吓得连看都不敢看我。
At this point, I started to get worried for Joshua. He had been reluctant even to go to Maureen's house, so I knew that at that point, as Maureen spoke his name, he was a shaky, disoriented mess.
此时，我开始为约书亚担心。他甚至都不情愿去莫琳家，所以我知道当莫琳说出他的名字时，他肯定已经吓得神魂颠倒了。
Can you ask Josh if he's nervous with you right now?
你能问问乔什现在和你在一起紧张吗？
Josh, are you nervous around me right now? He doesn't want to answer because I'm here.
乔什，你现在跟我在一起紧张吗？他不回答，因为我在场。
Can you just put him on the phone for one second so I can ask him?
你能把他叫到电话前让我问问吗？
Yeah. Here, hold on. He wants to ask you a question.
好的，等一下。他想问你个问题。
Hello?
喂？
[CLEARS THROAT]
[清嗓子]
Can you talk-- are you afraid to talk in front of her?
你能说吗——你在她面前害怕说话吗？
You know.
你懂的。
You're afraid. Just say yes if you're afraid.
你在害怕。如果你害怕就说是。
Yes.
是。
OK. Has she got you on your guard?
好的。她让你很有防备心吗？
Yeah, sure. Yeah, yeah.
对，没错。嗯。
When I was finished speaking with Maureen, I called Josh up on his cell phone, and he talked with me from his car.
我和莫琳谈完后，用手机给乔什打了电话，他是在车里跟我通话的。
It's so [BLEEP] hot in this car. I'm telling you, man, you should be paying me extra.
车里太[哔]热了。我跟你说，老兄，你得多给我付点钱。
So what was it like in there?
在那里感觉怎么样？
I got to tell you, it a little intimidating. There's a certain type of woman, usually either Jackie or related to Jackie, that really-- they know how to put me in my place.
我得告诉你，有点吓人。有某种类型的女人，通常是杰基或者杰基的亲戚，她们真的……她们知道怎么让我服帖。
So when she says that there are some people who crave to be abused, you would be one of those people?
所以当她说有些人渴望被虐待时，你就是其中之一？
She was looking directly at me when she said that. She was looking directly at me, and she was pointing at me with her index finger. Not a lot of mystery there.
她说那话时正看着我。她直视着我，还用食指指着我。这根本没悬念。
But why this allure? Why are we so drawn to these mean girls?
但为什么会有这种魅力？为什么我们会被这些刻薄女孩吸引？
Because they know. They look at you, and they know. Other women who are nice or who are too timid, they try to pretend that you're not who you are, which is garbage. But someone like Maureen and Jackie, they look right at you and say, I know you're garbage. You know you're garbage. Why pretend, you know? I'm never going with you. I'm marrying the dentist. I'm not even going to look at you.
因为她们知道。她们看着你，她们心里有数。其他那些友善或过于胆怯的女性，她们试图假装你不是你那个样，这简直是废话。但像莫琳和杰基这样的人，她们直视着你说：“我知道你是垃圾。你也知道你是垃圾。何必假装呢，对吧？我永远不会和你在一起。我要嫁给牙医。我甚至不会看你一眼。”
And you're going to come over to my house, which is the biggest house I've ever seen in my entire [BLEEP] life. And you're going to say, you see this garbage? This is what a real man provides for me. You come here and you tape me for your stupid friend's radio show, and then you get the hell out, while I pick up my children, whom I got through having sex with my dentist husband in my big [BLEEP] house. Now get the [BLEEP] out, garbage. Out!
然后你要来我家，这是我这辈子见过最大的[哔]房子。你会说：“你看到这些垃圾了吗？这就是真正的男人为我提供的。”你来到这儿录下我为你那个傻朋友的广播节目，然后立刻滚出去，而我要去接我的孩子们——那些是我和我牙医丈夫在我的大[哔]房子里做爱生下的。现在滚出去，垃圾。出去！
Well, I mean, with you, she thinks of you as a harmless eccentric, like a 90-year-old English guy puttering about in his garden. Me, she sees like an unwelcome dog turd that somebody's trekked in from outside. And it hurts me. It really hurts me. I mean, I think it would be too strong to say that I love Maureen, but I love Maureen.
嗯，我是说，对她而言，你只是个无害的怪人，就像一个在花园里慢悠悠逛着的90岁英国老头。而我，她看我就像是一个从外面带进来的、不受欢迎的狗屎。这很伤人。真的很伤我。我想说我爱莫琳可能太夸张了，但我确实爱莫琳。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I-- yeah. Want equals fear.
我——对。“想要”等于“恐惧”。
Wait, wait. Is it the fear that--
等等，等等。是因为那种恐惧吗——
Look, Jon, I'm not a sociologist. I don't know what's going on. I'm a piece of garbage to her, and it makes me want to just crawl up next to her like a flea on a tick on a tick on a dog. You know? I just want some of that good, good blood, even if it's my own blood.
听着，乔，我不是社会学家。我不知道怎么回事。对她来说我就是一堆垃圾，这让我只想像跳蚤一样贴在她身边，像狗身上的跳蚤那样。你知道吗？我只想尝尝那新鲜的血液，哪怕是我自己的血也行。
What about when Jackie said that saying that you could be "hi, bye" friends is actually a nice thing? What did you think of that? To that guy who asked her out.
当杰基说他们可以做“嗨，拜”朋友其实是一种友善时，你怎么看？对那个约她的家伙来说。
"Hi, bye" friends? You know what "hi, bye" friends really means? It means that when that guy went home later that night and hanged himself, that's the sound the rope made. Hi, bye, hi, bye, hi, bye, hi, bye.
“嗨，拜”朋友？你知道“嗨，拜”朋友真正意味着什么吗？这意味着当那家伙那天晚上回家自杀时，绳子发出的就是那个声音。嗨，拜，嗨，拜，嗨，拜，嗨，拜。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Jackie Cohen. Jackie Cohen. Do you miss that person that was able to do those kinds of things?
杰基·科恩。杰基·科恩。你会怀念那个曾经能做出那种事的人吗？
[SIGHS] No, but I think you do. I think you miss the mean Jackie Cohen. I think you really do. You inquire about her a lot. I think you do.
[叹气] 不，但我觉得你会。我觉得你怀念那个刻薄的杰基·科恩。我觉得你真的很怀念。你经常问起她。我觉得你怀念。
Is the sky that unleashes a bolt of lightning into the forehead of a friendly woodsman mean? Is it mean of the ravenous lion to devour the frightened zebra? As the first terrible bites sink into his legs and stomach, does the zebra look into the lion's eyes as though to say, why are you doing this to me, friend? And why, by my very nature, have I demanded it? When I bring all this up with Jackie, I realize that only the zebra would do a story like this. The lion could care less.
那种向友好的伐木工人额头劈下闪电的天空是刻薄的吗？贪婪的狮子吞噬受惊的斑马是刻薄的吗？当第一口可怕的撕咬陷入它的双腿和胃部时，斑马会看着狮子的眼睛，仿佛在说：“朋友，为什么要这么对我？”而为什么由于我的本性，我竟然要求它这么做？当我把这一切和杰基提及时，我意识到只有斑马才会写这样的故事。狮子才不在乎。
Jonathan Goldstein is a contributing editor to our program and host of Wiretap on CBC Radio One, and also available now on some public radio stations in this country.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是我们节目的特约编辑，也是CBC电台一号频道《窃听》（Wiretap）的主持人，该节目目前也在国内的一些公共广播电台播出。
Act 2, Does Niceness Pay? OK, sure. Niceness might not get you the most friends in high school. Niceness might not help your career in the NFL, or on the trading floor of the New York Stock Exchange, or in any super-competitive line of work. But you would think that there might be a place for it somewhere, like, for instance, waitressing. The whole point of the job is to help somebody else. Well, consider this story. A waitress in Chicago named Troy Morris was working a Friday night shift with another waitress, Amy Rigali. Here's Troy.
第二篇章：友善会有回报吗？好了，当然，友善在高中可能交不到最多的朋友。友善可能帮不了你的NFL职业生涯，或者纽交所的交易大厅，或者任何超高竞争力的工作。但你可能会想，总该有个地方有它的用武之地吧，比如说，当服务员。这份工作的全部意义就是帮助他人。嗯，来看看这个故事。芝加哥一位名叫特洛伊·莫里斯的服务员，周五晚上正和另一位服务员艾米·里加利一起上班。这是特洛伊。
I worked with her Friday night, and she was almost in tears because the tips, just for the last week, have been horrible, horrible, horrible. She's getting less than 15%. And so she couldn't stop thinking about it. And just every check, she'd look at it and just be like, I can't believe it. And she's just like, I can't do this anymore. Look at it. People hate me.
周五晚上我跟她一起上班，她差点哭出来，因为过去一周的小费简直太烂、太烂、太烂了。她拿到的小费不到15%。她停不下地在想，每结一单她都会看一眼，然后说：“我简直不敢相信。”她就是觉得：“我受不了了。你看。”人们讨厌我。
This is Amy.
这是艾米。
I don't know what I'm doing wrong. I'm trying so hard to do everything perfect. And all of these people are tipping me below.
我不知道自己做错了什么。我那么努力想把每件事做到完美，而这些人给我的小费都低于标准。
It made no sense. She'd been there for years, longer than anybody, knew the menu better, gave very quick service. And on the niceness scale, here's the word Troy uses to describe Amy.
这说不通。她在那里工作很多年了，比谁都长，菜单背得滚瓜烂熟，服务也非常迅速。关于友善程度，特洛伊用了一个词来描述艾米。
Super helpful. She's the sweetest person and smiles and is patient and caring.
超级热心。她是那种最甜美的人，总是微笑，耐心且体贴。
On Sunday, Amy worked again. And this time, Amy says, her attitude was different.
周日，艾米又上班了。这一次，艾米说，她的态度变了。
I definitely went into it with this attitude of giving up, just like, I wash my hands of this. I'm just going to serve them and walk away. Because I was so frustrated.
我确实抱着一种放弃的态度走进店里，就像是：“我不管了。我只负责上菜，然后走开。”因为我太沮丧了。
And what happened to your tips?
你的小费怎么了？
They were great. They were, a lot of them, over 20% It was wild.
非常棒。很多都超过了20%。太疯狂了。
And I came in, because we switch shifts. Like, she's getting off when I'm coming on. And she's just totally beaming, really happy. I made great tips. She's like, I can't believe it. Now I know what to do. [LAUGHS]
我进去的时候，因为我们要轮班。她在下班，我在接班。她简直笑开了花，非常高兴。“我拿到了很棒的小费。”她说：“我简直不敢相信。现在我知道该怎么做了。”[笑声]
Now I know what to do-- not be as nice?
现在我知道该怎么做了——不那么友善？
Yeah. Just not care.
对。就是不在乎。
We can actually quantify exactly how much niceness was costing Amy. The difference between 15% tips and 20% tips works out to around $50 per shift. Is it possible that any waitress could make more money by being less nice? We decided to do a little experiment to find out. We would wire two waitresses with hidden microphones and then have them be super nice to half their tables and cool, aloof, with the other half. They'd give equally good service to both tables.
我们可以量化友善到底让艾米损失了多少钱。15%小费和20%小费之间的差距大约是每班50美元。有没有可能服务员通过少一点友善能赚更多钱？我们决定做个小实验来查明真相。我们要给两个服务员佩戴隐藏麦克风，让她们对一半的顾客表现得超级友善，对另一半表现得冷淡、疏远。她们会对两组顾客提供同样优质的服务。
[RESTAURANT CHATTER]
[餐厅嘈杂声]
We did our experiment in the restaurant where Troy and Amy work, Lula Cafe in Chicago's Logan Square. It's the kind of place that everybody always wants to have in their neighborhood-- small, wonderful food that is also very cheap. Half the entrees cost $6 or so. There's Moroccan couscous. There's vegetarian sushi. There are lots of carefully made sandwiches. And then there's this whole menu of higher-end specials every day, so it's possible to drop $20 on a grilled sea bass or organically raised lamb.
我们在特洛伊和艾米工作的餐厅——芝加哥洛根广场的卢拉咖啡馆（Lula Cafe）进行了实验。这是那种每个人都希望自己街区拥有的餐厅：规模小，餐点绝妙而且非常便宜。一半的主菜价格在6美元左右。有摩洛哥小米饭，有素食寿司，有许多精心制作的三明治。每天还有一份高端特色菜菜单，所以花20美元点一份烤海鲈鱼或有机饲养的小羊肉也是可能的。
Amy had no interest in being wired for sound, but Troy was game. Like most of the staff, she's young-looking. She wore a neon zebra skirt and calf-high boots to work. Her arms were bare so you could see her tattoos.
艾米对佩戴录音设备没兴趣，但特洛伊愿意尝试。像大多数员工一样，她看起来很年轻。她穿着荧光斑马纹裙子和小腿靴上班。她的双臂裸露，可以看到文身。
OK, that is really good. It's a little bit of a lighter, brighter flavor.
好的，这真的不错。味道稍微清淡、明快一点。
Here she is with one of the tables that she's being nice to, table number 4, warning them off a glass of wine that she thinks won't go with her meal.
这是她对其中一组她表现得友善的顾客，4号桌，劝阻他们点一杯她觉得不适合当晚餐点的葡萄酒。
So just so you know, it's a little bit on the sweet side. You want something fuller? Is that what you're thinking?
所以你们得知道，这款稍微有点甜味。你们想要口感更浓郁一点的吗？你们是这样想的吗？
In two minutes, Troy has their whole story. They're visiting from out of town. They seem to be falling in love. And they found this very non-touristy, out-of-the-way place through careful research. She praises them on their homework.
两分钟内，特洛伊就知道了他们的故事。他们是外地来的，看起来坠入了爱河。他们是通过精心研究才找到这个游客稀少、非常冷门的地方。她称赞他们的“家庭作业”。
Good job, you guys.
干得好，你们。
Nice is her usual style as a waitress. She recommends specials. She chats. She's a sweetheart. Being aloof took a little more effort for her.
“友善”是她作为服务员的常态。她推荐特色菜，闲聊。她是个甜心。冷淡对她来说需要更多的努力。
So table 2 that just sat down, normally, I would have already talked to them, but I'm making them wait a little while.
所以刚坐下的2号桌，通常我早就去跟他们说话了，但我故意让他们等了一会儿。
When she finally goes to table 2, which has three serious-looking people in their 40s, she doesn't ask them how they are or if they have any questions about the menu. She doesn't recommend the sturgeon, which is her favorite, or anything else. These are her first and practically only words to table 2.
当她终于走向2号桌——坐着三个表情严肃的40多岁的人时，她没有问他们怎么样，或者对菜单有没有疑问。她没有推荐她最喜欢的鲟鱼，或其他任何东西。这就是她对2号桌说的第一句、也是几乎全部的话。
Hello. Have you guys decided?
您好，你们决定好了吗？
When they ask her to recommend a wine, she swallows and tells them--
当他们让她推荐酒时，她咽了下口水，告诉他们——
You know what? All those red wines will go good with what you're getting, [CHUCKLES] quite honestly.
你们知道吗？所有那些红葡萄酒搭配你们点的菜都会不错。[轻笑] 说实话。
And then there was the guy sitting at the bar alone, noticeably good-looking, reading The New York Times. Troy gave me the rundown.
还有一个独自坐在吧台的帅哥，正读着《纽约时报》。特洛伊给了我简报。
He's a regular guy that always sits there. He orders a lot, and he never tips great. He always tips just exactly 15%.
他是常客，一直坐在那儿。他点得很多，小费从来都不好。他总是只给15%。
Perfect for the experiment. Usually, Troy liked talking with him. If she played it aloof, would her tip go up? She walked over, and he asked her what she was up to these days.
正好适合实验。通常，特洛伊喜欢和他聊天。如果她表现得冷淡，小费会增加吗？她走过去，他问她最近在忙什么。
Oh, you know, working.
噢，你知道的，工作。
Did you change your hair, he said. Is it different?
“你换发型了吗？”他说，“不一样了吗？”
Maybe I washed it.
也许是我刚洗了头发。
And so hours pass. People finish their meals. And when Troy starts collecting their money, the early results all seem to point in one direction. Take table 2, the table she barely spoke with. Troy handed me their check.
时间一小时一小时过去。人们用餐完毕。当特洛伊开始收款时，早期的结果似乎都指向一个方向。以2号桌为例，那是她几乎没怎么交谈的桌子。特洛伊把账单交给了我。
How does it look?
看起来怎么样？
OK, doing a little math here, table 2, 17.6% is what they tipped.
好吧，算一下数学，2号桌，小费给了17.6%。
Oh, really? And I wasn't nice to them at all.
噢，真的吗？但我对他们一点都不友善。
And yet--
然而——
They tipped over 15%, which is good. I can't wait to see what table 5 tipped. Let me look.
他们给了超过15%的小费，这很棒。我迫不及待想看5号桌给了多少。让我看看。
Table 5 was the hardest table by far, very demanding. And she was very attentive.
5号桌是目前为止最难缠的桌子，要求非常多。而且她表现得非常细心。
Check this out.
看看这个。
OK, table 5, you were sucking up to. I've never--
好的，5号桌，你刚才是在拍马屁。我从未——
I was so nice to them.
我对他们太友善了。
I've never seen-- crazy.
我从未见过——太疯狂了。
I got them to-go food. I picked out their wine. I helped them--
我给他们打包食物，挑了酒，还帮他们——
It was a lot.
这太刻意了。
--figure out what food they wanted. And look, it was $84, and I got $13 tip. And I was so nice to them.
——决定想吃什么菜。结果你看，消费84美元，小费只有13美元。而且我对他们那么友善。
So that's just a little over 15%. Wow.
所以这也就刚过15%。哇。
And they were the most demanding. And I spent the most time with them than anybody.
而且他们是最难缠的。我花在他们身上的时间比谁都多。
But the biggest revelation of the night came when Troy retrieved the check from that guy who was sitting at the bar.
但当晚最大的启示来自特洛伊从吧台那个家伙手里收到的账单。
I can't believe this. Look at this. OK, remember the guy who I said, I'm always nice to him, but he always tips the minimal. He tipped 20%. I was mean to him for the first time. Look at-- can you believe that?
我简直不敢相信。看看这个。好，记得那个家伙吗？我说我对他总是很友善，但他总是只给最低限度。他给了20%。我破天荒第一次对他刻薄。看看这——你敢相信吗？
Wow. He tips $5--
哇。他给了5美元——
Over 20% never. That's never happened. And it totally-- I can't believe it. That's hilarious. But that's really disturbing. I have to be mean to him now, more.
从来没超过20%。这从来没发生过。这简直太……我简直不敢相信。太搞笑了。但这真的太让人不安了。我现在必须对他更刻薄一点。
By the end of the first night, it seemed pretty clear. Aloofness pays. But then when I came back a second night and hooked up a second waitress with a hidden wireless microphone, I got very different results. The second waitress, Callie Roach, is 23 with super-short hair. She laughs that a local restaurant reviewer referred to her in the paper as a "waif-tress."
第一晚结束时，结果似乎很明确。冷淡是有回报的。但当我第二天回来，给第二位服务员装上隐藏无线麦克风时，我得到了完全不同的结果。第二位服务员，卡莉·罗奇，23岁，留着超短发。她笑着说当地的餐厅评论员在报纸上称她为“苗条服务员”。
And on her night, everyone tipped 20% or even a touch more. That was true of the regulars who she was aloof to. It was true of the man who Callie doted on who was taking his grown daughter out to dinner. It was true of the couple who Callie joked around with about their difficult-to-open bottle of wine.
在她的那天晚上，每个人都给了20%甚至更多的小费。不管是她态度冷淡的常客，还是被卡莉精心照料、带成年女儿出来吃饭的男士，甚至是和卡莉开玩笑讨论那瓶极难打开的葡萄酒的情侣，都是如此。
After the struggle.
挣扎之后。
Yeah. I've got little hand hickeys. I'm like, geez, this--
对。我手都起水泡了。我心想：“天哪，这——”
Even the other waitress working on Wednesday, Natalie, who does not have an aloof bone in her body, was getting 20% and more from every table. And the more I talked to Callie and Troy and Amy and the rest of the staff, the more everyone agreed. The majority of their customers are just set in their ways. They'll give whatever they always give in any restaurant like this to any server.
甚至周三上班的另一位服务员娜塔莉，她身上根本没有冷淡的细胞，也从每桌拿到了20%以上的小费。我和卡莉、特洛伊、艾米以及其他员工谈得越多，大家就越一致。他们的大多数顾客都有自己的习惯。无论在这样的餐厅遇到什么样的服务员，他们都会给他们一贯给的钱。
Sure, you get a handful of customers like the guy Troy waited on at the bar who you can nudge this way or that through force of personality. But it's just a few tables every shift. And that's all Troy and I were seeing that first night. This is Natalie.
当然，你会遇到像特洛伊在吧台服务的那个家伙那样，可以通过个性力量 nudge（推动）他们一下的少数顾客。但每班只有那么几桌。那也是特洛伊和我第一晚看到的一切。这是娜塔莉。
50% of the people will tip exactly the same, whether they get great service or-- they might tip a little less for lousy service. But most people, they tip what they're going to tip. Or I've noticed a lot of people just look at the first two numbers on the check and double it or round down. There's a pattern. And people tip the same.
50%的人给的小费完全一样，不管他们得到的是很棒的服务还是——服务很糟糕可能会少给一点。但大多数人，他们打算给多少就给多少。或者我注意到很多人只是看着账单前两位数字然后加倍或者向下取整。有个规律。大家给的小费都一样。
I think, generally, if you're not chatty and overly nice, you'll still get the same tip.
我觉得，通常来说，如果你不喋喋不休、表现得过度友善，你依然能拿到同样的小费。
Here's Callie.
卡莉说。
You can just tell that people are going to tip you 18% because they got their food when they wanted it. And it doesn't matter how much you're giggling and inquisitive. Like Sundays, Sundays, I usually get tipped $4 or $5 every table. Doesn't matter what I do.
你可以看出来，人们会给你18%的小费，因为他们按时拿到了餐点。至于你笑得多么开心、多么好奇，根本无关紧要。比如周日，周日我每桌通常能拿到4或5美元小费。我做什么都一样。
Because of this, she says, she has a policy-- and she's only half-joking as she says this-- that she tries to limit the number of times that she smiles at customers or shows her approval to exactly two times. Two times. First time, when they place their order. She always tells them what a very fine choice they made, and then she smiles. And then, at the end of the meal, she drops off the check, and she smiles a second time, as if to say, you see? I do like you. If it's done wrong, she says, friendliness not only will not pay, friendliness can cost you.
正因如此，她说，她有个原则——她说的时候只是一半开玩笑——她尝试限制自己对顾客微笑或展示赞同的次数为正好两次。两次。第一次，在他们点菜时。她总是告诉他们做出了多么好的选择，然后微笑。第二次，在餐后，她放下账单时，她会微笑第二次，好像在说：“看吧？我确实喜欢你。”如果做得不对，她说，友善不仅不会有回报，友善反而可能让你损失金钱。
Because if you're nice and enjoying yourself, they don't need to make you feel any better. They already think you're having a good time. That's my theory, is they already think you're having a good time. Why are they going to tip you for having fun, you know? If you're like-- if you're doing it just to get through it, they know that you're working.
因为如果你表现得友善、乐在其中，他们就没必要让你感觉更好了。他们已经觉得你在享受当下了。这是我的理论，他们已经觉得你玩得很开心。他们为什么要为你玩得开心而付小费呢？如果你像——如果你只是表现出为了应付工作，他们知道你在工作。
Troy and Amy have also decided that niceness has its limits. For the first time in their years of waitressing, because of these discussions, in the last two weeks, they have both stopped knocking themselves out, running around for their most demanding tables. They're efficient. They're pleasant. But that's it. This is what they've learned. It's not that aloofness pays. It's that niceness doesn't pay.
特洛伊和艾米也认为友善是有极限的。因为这些讨论，在她们当服务员的这么多年里，过去两周，她们都不再为了最难缠的顾客而累死累活，到处奔波了。她们表现得很高效，很亲切。但也仅此而已。这就是她们学到的。并不是冷淡有回报，而是友善没回报。
Thanks to the owners of the Lula Cafe. That first waitress, Troy Morris, and one of the owners of the cafe, Lea Tshields, were in the band Tallulah. This song is from the band's album, Step Into the Stars.
感谢卢拉咖啡馆的店主。第一位服务员特洛伊·莫里斯和咖啡馆的一位店主莉·特希尔德曾在塔卢拉乐队中。这首歌来自该乐队的专辑《踏入星辰》（Step Into the Stars）。
Coming up, if you seem so nice, why do I feel so bad? And more. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果你看起来那么友善，为什么我觉得那么难受？还有更多内容。芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司稍后为您带来，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, the allure of the mean friend. What is it about? We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, And What's Going On With You? We have this from Mike Albo.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同故事。今天的主题是“刻薄朋友”的魅力。这是关于什么的？我们已经到了节目的第三篇章。第三篇章：你最近怎么样？这是来自迈克·阿尔博的故事。
You're here early. Oh, my god, do you have my scarf? Did you bring it? No, that's OK. No, it's just that I got it in India when I was there, and it's just this really beautiful thing. And I really treasure it. It's just really important to me. It's not like the cheaply-made Barneys co-op stuff that you buy. I don't mean "you buy." I mean "you buy." Oh, I wish you would have remembered. No, that's OK. You're so flaky.
你来得真早。噢，天哪，你有我的围巾吗？你带了吗？不，没关系。不，只是我在印度的时候买的，那是件非常美丽的艺术品。我真的很珍惜它。它对我来说真的很重要。不像你买的那些巴尼斯百货廉价货。我不是指“你买”，我是说“你买”。噢，我真希望你能记住。不，没关系。你真健忘。
Are you sick? You look sort of tired. Is there something wrong? Oh, you went out drinking last night? It's so great how you can still do that. You're so crazy. Did you throw up? Oh, no, I just smelled throw up for a second.
你生病了吗？你看起来有点累。有什么不对吗？噢，你昨晚出去喝酒了？你能做到那一点真的很厉害。你真疯狂。你吐了吗？噢，不，我只是刚才闻到了呕吐的味道。
OK, so I didn't want you to hear this from someone else, but I just made $2 million. Yeah, so I'm pretty happy about it. My agent's pretty happy about it. It's just really lucky because with the recession, it's like I made my money before the apocalypse, and I'll be able to live comfortably. It's just sort of locked in. And I can't tell you about the details of the deal, but if you could just do me a huge, huge favor and just don't mention it to anyone. I know you have a problem being discreet.
好了，我不想让你从别人那儿听到，但我刚刚赚了200万美元。是的，所以我很高兴。我的经纪人也很高兴。这真的很幸运，因为经济衰退，我在末日之前赚到了钱，我可以活得很舒服。这都已经锁定好了。我不能告诉你交易的细节，但如果你能帮我一个巨大的、巨大的忙，千万别跟别人提。我知道你很难保守秘密。
Oh, order something? Oh, no. No, I'm not drinking anymore. Oh, no. Go ahead. Have fun. I'm just not drinking anymore. I just realized there's a little bit more to life. But go ahead. Have fun. You're so crazy. So what's up with you? Oh my god, when was the last time I saw you? I am totally hanging out with Tobey Maguire and Reese and Ryan and David Blaine. [CHUCKLES] We jokingly call it the Millionaires' Club.
噢，点餐了吗？噢，不，我不再喝酒了。噢，不。去吧，玩得开心。我只是不再喝酒了。我只是意识到生活中还有比这更重要的东西。但去吧，玩得开心。你真疯狂。所以你最近怎么样？噢，天哪，上次见你是什么时候？我正在和托比·马奎尔、瑞茜、瑞安和大卫·布莱恩待在一起。[轻笑] 我们开玩笑叫它“百万富翁俱乐部”。
Oh, you know that children's book I wrote really fast for no reason, It's a Funny Sunny Day? Well, I just found out it's selling like crazy and can barely stay on the shelves. And I got another voiceover gig. It's weird. They just like my voice. I don't even have to leave home. I just call it in. Oh, no, it's-- I just sort of fell into it. You should try it. But it's really hard to get into. But you should try it.
噢，你知道我写的那本关于《搞笑晴天》的童书吗？我刚刚发现它卖得疯了，货架上几乎供不应求。我又接了一个配音活。真奇怪，他们就是喜欢我的声音。我甚至不需要离开家，打个电话就行。噢，不，它是——我只是碰巧赶上了。你也该试试。但很难挤进去，不过你该试试。
You're looking for a place? Good luck. God, it's so hard to find a good place right now. This guy called me and begged me to take his beautiful 4,000-square-foot loft space. It's $300, but he's actually paying me to live there forever.
你在找地方住？祝你好运。天哪，现在很难找到好地方。有个家伙求我租下他那漂亮的4000平方英尺的阁楼。租金是300美元，但他实际上付钱让我永远住在那儿。
So what's going on with you? I think your body looks good. It's normal. It's a normal body. Really? Well, that's too bad. Well, I just feel like you need a little bit more confidence in yourself. I feel like I'm a direct person. I say what I feel. You're more-- you're more-- I don't know what you are. But I have to say, I don't know how you do it. I'm so glad I'm not single. It looks so hard.
所以你最近怎么样？我觉得你的身体看起来不错。很正常，是一个正常的身体。真的吗？那太糟糕了。我只是觉得你需要对自己更有自信。我觉得我是一个直率的人，我说出我的感受。你更……你更……我不知道你是什么。但我得说，不知道你是怎么做到的。我很高兴我不是单身。看起来太难了。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, I just ran into Carl. No. He looks good. He's good. He's good. Yeah, he says he hasn't talked to you. No. He seems like he's moving forward. I mean, you guys broke up, and he's just sort of moving on with his life. He's in this really good relationship right now, and they just bought this huge, beautiful place upstate and they're fixing it up together.
噢，是的。是的，我刚才碰见卡尔了。不。他看起来不错。他很好，他很好。是的，他说他没跟你谈过。不。他看起来在前进。我是说，你们分手了，他在继续自己的生活。他现在有一段非常好的感情，他们刚在上州买了一套巨大漂亮的房子，正在一起翻修。
We just had a really good time talking. And you know what? He's been working out. His body looks amazing. When you and Carl were going out, I never really understood why you liked him. But now I totally do. So nothing's going on with you? [LAUGHS] No, I'm sorry. I'm just remembering a funny joke that Carl told me. What? No, I'm listening.
我们刚才聊得很开心。你知道吗？他在健身，身体看起来棒极了。当你和卡尔交往时，我从来不明白你为什么喜欢他。但现在我完全明白了。所以你最近没什么进展？[笑声] 不，抱歉，我只是想起了卡尔讲的一个好笑的笑话。什么？不，我在听。
An excerpt from Mike Albo's short story, "The Underminer." Mike Albo also has a longer work, a book called The Underminer that he co-wrote with Virginia Heffernan.
迈克·阿尔博短篇小说《削弱者》（The Underminer）摘录。迈克·阿尔博还有一部更长的作品，一本他与弗吉尼亚·赫弗南合著的书，书名也叫《削弱者》。
Act Four, Keeping it in the Family. Of course you can evade a mean friend. A mean relative, however, is forever. This next story is an excerpt from a much longer work by Bernard Cooper. This story follows Cooper's father as he eventually goes to a psychiatric hospital. But what happens in this part of the story takes place a while before that. The actor Josh Hamilton read it for us.
第四篇章：家务事。当然你可以躲开刻薄的朋友。然而，刻薄的亲戚是永远的。接下来的故事是伯纳德·库珀一部长篇作品的摘录。这个故事讲述了库珀父亲最终住进精神病院的过程。但这一部分发生在那之前的一段时间。演员乔什·汉密尔顿为我们读了这段。
When I was 28 years old, my father sent me a bill for his paternal services. Typed on his law firm's onion skin stationery, the bill itemized the money he'd spent on me over my lifetime. Since he hadn't kept tabs on the exact amounts he'd doled out over the years, expenditures were rounded off to the nearest dollar and labeled food, clothing, tuition, and incidentals. Beneath the tally, in the firm but detached language common to his profession, he demanded that I pay him back.
我28岁那年，父亲给我寄来了一张关于他“父爱服务”的账单。这张账单打印在他所在律所的洋葱皮纸信笺上，详细列出了他这一生为我花费的金钱。由于他并没有记录这些年来他支出的具体金额，所以金额按美元四舍五入，并标记为食品、服装、学费和杂费。在总计下方，用他职业中常见的坚决而冷漠的口吻，他要求我偿还。
The total was somewhere in the neighborhood of $2 million, an especially hefty sum in 1978. I remember being impressed by the amount. What an expensive life I'd lived. I was shocked and insulted, too, of course, not only because my father had made such a calculation, but because my life could be added up or reduced to a single figure. To see your existence in the form of a bill gives all your loves and fears and struggles the cumulative tumult of being human about as much poignancy as a check for a cup of coffee.
总额大约在200万美元左右，这在1978年是一笔相当庞大的数字。我记得当时对这个数目感到震惊。我过的一生竟然如此昂贵。当然，我也感到震惊和受侮辱，不仅是因为父亲做了这样的计算，而且因为我的一生竟然可以加起来或缩减为一个单一的数字。以账单的形式回顾自己的一生，让所有的爱、恐惧和挣扎都失去了作为人类的那种澎湃感，其凄凉程度和一张咖啡账单没什么区别。
It read, "Your obligations to your father, the party of the first part, are considerable. And the only way to impress upon you, the party of the second part, the necessity of compensating him for the fiscal burdens he bore on your behalf is to make his sacrifices evident in the form of the following, recorded herein as a legal and binding document. Should you fail to make payment in full, this matter will result in actions for which I advise you to hire counsel."
上面写着：“作为第一方，你对父亲的义务是巨大的。而要让你这个第二方意识到补偿他所承担的财政负担的必要性，唯一的方法就是通过以下形式让他的牺牲显而易见，此文件记录在案，具有法律约束力。若未能全额付款，此事将导致相关行动，我建议你聘请法律顾问。”
I double-checked his signature. It was his, all right, the letters rich with loops and convolutions. Go ahead, I thought. Let him dun me. See if I pay. No parent in his right mind asks his child to reimburse him for that child's life. I didn't ask to be born, I thought melodramatically. Besides, had I known I'd be charged for my boyhood, I might have eaten fewer snacks, been easier on my shoes, more frugal with my allowance.
我仔细核对了签名。确实是他的，字母里充满了圆圈和卷曲。随便吧，我想。让他催吧。看看我会不会付钱。没有哪个理智的父母会要求孩子报销那个孩子的生命费。我想得有点夸张：“我可没要求出生。”此外，如果我早知道会因为童年而被收费，我可能会少吃点零食，少穿点鞋子，零花钱也会更节俭一点。
I couldn't help but dream up a doozy of a counterclaim, its itemizations even more preposterous than my father's. Chronic insecurity-- $90,000. Narcissistic wound-- $75,000. Oedipal complex-- $7,000.
我忍不住构思了一个反诉账单，列出的项目甚至比我父亲的还要荒谬。慢性不安全感——9万美元。自恋伤口——7.5万美元。俄狄浦斯情结——7000美元。
Since, of course, these damages were psychological in nature, it was both difficult and whimsical to assign them a monetary value. But the punitive spirit of this counterclaim was gratifying, for a while, at least. Then the whole petty endeavor depressed me, and I thought, is this what we are to each other-- a flurry of demands that can't be met, hurts for which there's no restitution?
由于这些损害在本质上是心理层面的，分配货币价值既困难又异想天开。但这种反诉的惩罚精神至少在一段时间内让我感到满足。然后整个琐碎的努力让我陷入消沉，我想：这就是我们对彼此的意义吗——一连串无法满足的要求，无法补偿的伤害？
During the restless days and nights that followed, I couldn't settle on a convincing or comprehensible reason to explain why my father had sent me the bill, though I suspected the catalyst might have had something to do with his offer a few months earlier to buy me a new car. He'd made the offer on a day I'd come to visit him at his Spanish house in Hollywood, the house in which I'd grown up. As I pulled into the driveway, he was busy watering birds of paradise in his front yard, sturdy orange flowers that he'd cultivated, to his constant astonishment, from a bed of drab gravel.
在随后的不安日子里，我始终找不到一个令人信服的理由来解释为什么父亲会寄给我这张账单，尽管我怀疑诱因可能与他几个月前提出给我买辆新车有关。他是在我那天去好莱坞他那栋西班牙式房子（我长大的地方）看望他时提出这个建议的。我开车进车道时，他正忙着在院子里浇天堂鸟，那种结实的橙色花朵，令他一直惊叹不已的是，它们竟然从乱石堆中培育了出来。
Back then, I drove a Fiat whose paint had oxidized to the overall color and texture of rust. The car sputtered as I shifted into park, and the sagging tailpipe, which I'd had to bind to the car's undercarriage with electrical tape, coughed a cloud of noxious exhaust. Just a year after I purchased the car with money from a small inheritance left me by my mother, it fell apart with an almost vengeful rapidity.
那时，我开着一辆菲亚特，车漆已经氧化成了一种锈迹斑斑的颜色和质感。我挂入停车挡时，车子发出噼啪声，下垂的排气管——我必须用绝缘胶带把它绑在车底盘上——咳嗽出一团有害的废气。那辆车是我用母亲留给我的小额遗产买的，仅仅一年后，它就以一种近乎报复性的速度散架了。
The vinyl upholstery of the bucket seats began to rub off on passengers' hands and thighs in sticky black patches. Soon, the seats were nothing but lumps of raw foam, and even those were crumbling like sponge cake. One of the rear windows no longer rolled up, the pane trapped within the door. On cold nights, a stray dog made the backseat its home, leaving behind a legion of fleas to feast on my ankles as I drove around town.
桶形座椅的乙烯基垫子开始在乘客的手和大腿上摩擦出粘稠的黑色斑点。很快，座椅只剩下一堆原始泡沫，连那些也像海绵蛋糕一样崩解。后窗之一再也摇不起来，玻璃卡在门里。寒冷的夜晚，一只流浪狗把后座当成了家，留下了大量的跳蚤在我开车时大快朵颐。
It was humiliating to be seen inside the car, especially in Los Angeles. When idling at a stoplight beside a purring sports car with rear stabilizers, anodized hubcaps, and a leather interior, I had to force myself to remember that an automobile does not a man make, and that I was a writer who placed a higher value on words than on material possessions, which is to say that I cultivated a hollow sense of superiority around new cars.
坐在车里很丢人，特别是在洛杉矶。当我在交通灯前怠速，旁边停着一辆带有后稳定器、阳极氧化轮毂和皮革内饰的流汗跑车时，我必须强迫自己记住，汽车不能定义男人，我是一个作家，比起物质财富，我更看重文字，换句话说，我在新车周围培养了一种空洞的优越感。
My father sauntered toward the Fiat as I got out, peeking through the perpetually open window, despite my attempt to block his view. Stocky and balding in a state of continual agitation, my father was also capable of a tenderness that seemed to light him from within, and that stirred me like daybreak stirs a bird. "Hey," he said. "Looks like you could use a new set of wheels."
我下车时，父亲向菲亚特走来，尽管我试图挡住他的视线，他还是从那扇永远关不上的窗户往里看。父亲身材敦实、秃顶，总是处于躁动不安的状态，但也具备一种仿佛从内心点亮他的温柔，让我像黎明唤醒鸟儿一样心头震颤。“嘿，”他说，“看起来你需要一套新车轮。”
"I can't afford a new car," I told him. I distinctly recall facing my father, his gardening clothes stained with grass and darkened by perspiration, and shaping my tone so that I sounded neither pitiful-- "I'm too poor"-- or petulant-- "I'll never be able to buy a new car."
“我买不起新车，”我告诉他。我清楚地记得面对着父亲，他那件沾满草屑、被汗水浸湿的园艺服，我控制着自己的语调，既听起来不凄惨——“我很穷”——也不任性——“我永远买不起新车”。
Before I knew it, my father and I were ensconced in his white El Dorado, gliding with the frictionless speed of a dream toward a Toyota dealership in West Covina, whose ads he'd seen on TV. He pointed a stubby finger at his chest. "Let me handle this," he said. "I've bought plenty of cars in my life, and I know how to deal with these bastards. You watch. I'll beat them at their own game. They won't know what hit them."
不知怎么地，我和父亲已经坐在他那辆白色埃尔多拉多（El Dorado）轿车里，正以梦幻般的无摩擦速度滑向西科维纳的一家丰田经销商，他在电视上看过那儿的广告。他用粗壮的手指指着自己的胸口：“让我来处理这个，”他说，“我这辈子买过很多车，我知道怎么对付这些混蛋。你看着。我会以其人之道还治其人之身。他们会不知道发生了什么。”
On one hand, Dad's braggadocio made me feel invincible, as though I were in the company of a seasoned pro. On the other hand, it relegated me to the role of admiring onlooker and suggested that I was too incompetent and naive to buy my own car, which was entirely true.
一方面，父亲的吹嘘让我觉得自己无坚不摧，仿佛陪同着一位经验丰富的专家。另一方面，这把我降级为欣赏的旁观者，暗示我太无能、太幼稚，无法买自己的车，而这完全是事实。
I floundered when it came to the treacherous etiquette of negotiating a major sale, a feat which required, it seemed to me, a keen mistrust of one's fellow men, coupled with a barely sublimated bloodlust. As far as I was concerned, getting gypped out of a few bucks was simply a built-in fee for avoiding confrontations with strangers.
在处理重大销售的危险礼仪时，我感到束手无策，在我看来，这需要对他人保持强烈的怀疑，加上几乎压抑不住的嗜血感。对我而言，被骗走几美元仅仅是避免与陌生人对抗的必要费用。
I'd watched my father often enough to know that such transactions excited him into what can only be described as a rapture of antagonism. He didn't mind yelling threats and pounding desks and generally hurling himself bodily into the arena of commerce. Still, if a new car required me to be embarrassed by his aggression, bring on the blushing. And so I let myself relax into the plush bucket seat, cradled and safe as the caddy whizzed past slower traffic, huge and unassailable, as regal as a motorized mansion.
我观察过父亲很多次，知道这种交易让他进入了一种可以被称为“对抗的狂喜”的状态。他不介意大吼威胁、重锤桌子，或者把自己彻底投入商业角逐。然而，如果新车要求我为他的攻击性感到羞耻，那就脸红吧。于是，我放松地靠在舒适的桶形座椅上，在凯迪拉克超越慢速车辆时，感觉既被呵护又安全，那庞大、不可动摇的姿态，就像是一座带马达的官邸。
As we walked across the asphalt lot of the Toyota dealership, triangular plastic pendants rippled and snapped in the breeze. I thanked Dad in advance and told him that I didn't need white walls and air conditioner or a radio. Basic transportation would be just fine. He nodded and forged ahead, his stride martial, his shoulders squared.
当我们走过丰田经销店的柏油停车场时，塑料三角旗在微风中摇曳拍打。我提前感谢了父亲，并告诉他我不需要白壁轮胎、空调或收音机。基本的交通工具就行了。他点点头，大步向前，步伐矫健，肩膀方正。
Secretly, I hoped my modest expectations might endear me to him even more. Maybe he'd close the deal that very day, before his mood changed, before I said something that would inadvertently set him off, before he said "crap" or "bastard" to the dealer.
私下里，我希望我那谦逊的期望能让他更疼爱我。也许他那天就能谈成交易，赶在他心情改变之前，赶在我说出什么 inadvertently（无意中）惹怒他的话之前，赶在他对经销商说“废话”或“混蛋”之前。
My excitement was indistinguishable from panic. I wanted a beautiful new Toyota more desperately with every step. I wanted an end to the self-consciousness I felt on the road, an end to the shameful sense that the thunderous rumbling and rank exhaust were coming from my person, rather than my car.
我的兴奋和恐慌无法分辨。每走一步，我就越发绝望地想要一辆漂亮的新丰田。我想要结束在路上的自我意识，结束那种羞耻的感触：那雷鸣般的轰鸣声和难闻的废气来自我自己，而不是我的车。
The showroom felt bracingly cool after the heat of West Covina. Highlights glittered in the flawless paint jobs of the display models. In the center of the room, a sleek new convertible turned around and around on an enormous platform, as if swooning to the muzak.
在西科维纳的热浪之后，陈列室里凉爽得令人振奋。展示车完美车漆里的亮点闪闪发光。房间中央，一辆时髦的新敞篷车在巨大的平台上转来转去，仿佛为背景音乐而神魂颠倒。
The second we entered, salespeople, sensing prey, rose from their desks and converged. It occurred to me that we would be the prize for the fastest walker, the one whose handshake or hail greeting reached us first. The victor was a skinny man whose snug black suit lent him an eel-like iridescence. Or perhaps I was just seeing him as my father might-- slippery, unctuous, not to be trusted.
我们一进门，销售人员感受到猎物，从桌边起身汇聚而来。我想到我们成了走路最快者的战利品，那个握手或问候最先达到我们面前的人赢了。胜者是个瘦子，合身的黑西装让他带有一种像鳗鱼一样的虹彩。或者我只是以父亲可能会有的视角看着他——滑溜、油滑、不可信赖。
Dad shifted his weight to meet the man's gaze, his posture erect. He kicked a tire as if to gauge through his knowing toes the vehicle's overall quality. He squinted at the sticker price. "John," said my father, reading the salesman's name tag, "Firstly, I'm an attorney. Secondly, when it comes to cars, I'm not some idiot off the street. A cousin of mine is fleet manager of a Cadillac dealership in San Bernardino"-- a complete fabrication, as far as I know. "If we cut through the crap, you just might make yourself a sale. My son here-- I'm buying the boy a car-- doesn't need any bells or whistles."
父亲变换重心去迎接那个男人的目光，身姿挺拔。他踢了踢轮胎，仿佛用他那双识货的脚趾在评估汽车的整体质量。他眯着眼看标签价。“约翰，”父亲念着销售员的名牌说，“首先，我是律师。其次，说到车，我不是那种路边的白痴。我有个堂兄是圣贝纳迪诺凯迪拉克经销店的总经理”——据我所知，这完全是编造的。“如果我们少说废话，你可能真能谈成一单。我儿子——我在给这孩子买车——不需要任何花里胡哨的东西。”
"I'm Bernard," I said to the salesman. He shook my hand without taking his eyes off my father. "Well, Mister--" "Cooper. Edward, attorney at law." "I gotta hand it to you, Mr. Cooper. It's nice to meet a customer who knows what he wants and comes prepared to do business. Makes my job a whole lot easier." My father shot me a sidelong glance, as if to say, watch and learn.
“我是伯纳德，”我对销售员说。他握了握我的手，视线始终没离开我父亲。“噢，库珀先生——” “库珀。爱德华，律师。” “我得佩服你，库珀先生。很高兴见到一位知道自己想要什么并且准备好做生意的顾客。这让我的工作轻松多了。”父亲斜眼瞥了我一下，仿佛在说：看着，学着点。
"I'm going to make this painless," said the salesman. He spun on his heel and walked toward the glass door that led to the lot. We followed him outside to a veritable poppy field of new Corollas, till we reached a red two-door that John claimed was the least expensive automobile on the lot.
“我让过程变得无痛，”销售员说。他转身向通往停车场的玻璃门走去。我们跟着他来到一大片卡罗拉轿车组成的“罂粟花田”，直到走到一辆红色的双门车前，约翰声称这是停车场里最便宜的一辆。
"This is the cheapest?" asked my father. Though it pains me to do so, I must add that my father's gold Star of David had loosed itself from the mid interior of his shirt to glint conspicuously in the afternoon light, the sight of which, given my father's unabashed haggling, caused a chord of shame to vibrate inside me. I felt compelled to explain to the salesman how my father had worked hard for everything he owned. He was a hoarder, a scrimper, a seeker of bargains who could never take his solvency for granted. And in this respect, he was like thousands of people who'd grown up poor and endured the Depression, Jewish or not.
“这是最便宜的？”父亲问道。尽管我很痛苦，但我必须补充一点，父亲金色的“大卫之星”项链已经从他衬衫内侧滑了出来，在午后的阳光下闪闪发光，考虑到父亲毫不掩饰的讨价还价，这景象让我内心产生了一股羞耻感。我感到有必要向销售员解释我父亲是如何为他拥有的一切努力工作的。他是个囤积者、吝啬鬼、 bargain（便宜货）的搜寻者，他从不能将自己的偿付能力视为理所当然。在这方面，他就像成千上万在贫困中成长并忍受了大萧条的人一样，无论是否是犹太人。
But that was a lot to explain to a salesman, especially on the cusp of a deal that would change my life. And to put it bluntly, if my father was conforming to the cliché of the cheap Jew, I was that cliché as beneficiary. I peered at the car, feigning disinterest. Quite a performance, considering how I coveted that little red Corolla.
但这对于一个销售员来说太难解释了，尤其是在即将改变我人生的交易关口。坦白说，如果父亲在遵循“吝啬犹太人”的刻板印象，我就是作为受益人的那种刻板印象。我盯着车子，装出不在意的样子。这表演真是太棒了，考虑到我有多渴望那辆红色的小卡罗拉。
"Mr. Cooper," said the salesman, "I know a shrewd man when I see one, and I'm going to do something that could put my job on the line. But before I tell you what it is, Mr. Cooper, I want you to promise that you won't say a word to my boss." I'd once heard that repeating a person's name is a way to make them feel important, to win them over. And John, it seemed, had heard the same.
“库珀先生，”销售员说，“我见到聪明人一眼就能认出来，我打算做点可能让我丢饭碗的事。但在我告诉你是什么之前，库珀先生，我希望你答应别跟我老板提一个字。”我曾听说重复一个人的名字是让他们感觉自己很重要、从而赢取信任的方法。看起来约翰也听说过同样的话。
"Mr. Cooper, I'm going to let you drive out of here for a mere $200 over the factory price. I'm going to scratch my commission on this. Frankly, I need the sales points more than I need the money. And if we can lock up this deal pronto, it'll be worth my while, and, of course, worth yours." Here, metabolism obscures memory. My heart was running on all cylinders. My mouth went dry.
“库珀先生，我让你以仅比工厂价格高出200美元的价格开走这辆车。我甚至不拿这单的佣金了。坦白说，我比需要钱更需要销售积分。如果我们能 pronto（迅速）敲定这笔交易，这对我也值得，当然，对你也值得。”在这里，新陈代谢模糊了记忆。我的心脏全速运转，嘴巴干渴。
"You've got to be [BLEEP] me, John," said my father, "I know you can give it to me under factory. I'm not paying a penny more than factory, period." "As I said, Mr. Cooper, I don't mind giving up my commission, but I can't lose money on the deal. I'm giving you the best price you're going to find in LA County, in the state of California."
“你一定是在[哔]我，约翰，”父亲说，“我知道你能给工厂价以下的。我一分钱都不会多付，period（到此为止）。” “正如我所说，库珀先生，我不介意放弃佣金，但我不能在交易中亏钱。我给你的是在洛杉矶县、加利福尼亚州你能找到的最好价格。”
Other customers were milling uncomfortably close to my Corolla, trying out driver's seats, adjusting rear view mirrors. I wanted to turn to my father and blurt, why would he lie? "I'm not buying it," my father said sternly. It took me a second to realize he meant the dealer's story, not the car itself.
其他顾客在卡罗拉周围走动，很不舒服地靠得很近，试驾驾驶座，调整后视镜。我想转向父亲脱口而出：他为什么要撒谎？“我不买了，”父亲严厉地说。我花了一秒钟才意识到他说的是销售员的故事，而不是车本身。
"I know how this game is played, and I'll play along up to a point, but we've reached that point. So let's see what kind of deal you can give me." "Shop around if you don't believe me, Mr. Cooper. Then come on back. The offer still stands. Better act quickly, though, because this baby isn't going to stay on the lot much longer."
“我知道这游戏怎么玩，我会配合到一定程度，但我们已经到了那个点。所以让我们看看你能给我什么样的交易。” “如果你不信我，库珀先生，去货比三家吧。然后再回来。报价依然有效。不过动作要快，因为这宝贝在这儿停不了多久了。”
"I guess you didn't hear me," said my father. "Look at me, Mr. Cooper. I have no reason to lead you on." My father gave John the once over, then turned to me. "Let's go," he said. "We're taking our business elsewhere."
“我想你没听清我的话，”父亲说。“看着我，库珀先生。我没理由蒙你。”父亲打量了约翰一眼，然后转向我。“走吧，”他说，“我们要去别处做生意。”
Before we took a step, the salesman curtly thanked my father and walked away. The two of us waited a moment with the tacit understanding that his retreat might have been a strategy to provoke my father into giving chase. The sun beat down from a cloudless sky, asphalt softening beneath our feet. "I think he's basically an honest man," I mumbled.
在我们迈步之前，销售员冷冷地感谢了父亲然后走开了。我们两人等了一会儿，心照不宣地认为他的撤退可能是一种策略，为了激怒父亲去追赶。阳光从无云的天空直射下来，脚下的柏油路在变软。“我觉得他基本上是个诚实的人，”我咕哝道。
"Honest, my ass." My father looked at me with something like pity. I'd never catch on, would forever remain a sucker, a rube. Muzak faintly wafted from the showroom as the salesman swung the door open and walked inside. "Well," Dad announced, "show's over." And we trudged across the lot toward his Caddy.
“诚实？我呸。”父亲看着我，眼神里有一种同情。我永远也不会开窍，永远是个傻瓜、乡巴佬。背景音乐从陈列室隐约飘出，销售员推开门走进了室内。“好了，”父亲宣布，“演出结束了。”我们拖着沉重的步伐穿过停车场走向他的凯迪拉克。
The drive back to Los Angeles took a good 40 minutes. My father still fumed from the encounter with the salesman, his ears and neck flushed with blood. Dad insisted that the deal was far from over. "The guy's playing hardball, but you watch. The phone will be ringing when we get back to the house. It'll be him. And he'll say--" My father launched into an imitation of John, cooing, Mr. Cooper this and Mr. Cooper that.
回洛杉矶的车程花了足足40分钟。父亲仍然因为和那个销售员的冲突而愤愤不平，他的耳朵和脖子被血充得通红。父亲坚称交易还远未结束。“那家伙在耍强硬手段，但你看着。我们回到家时电话会响的。会是他。他会说——” 父亲模仿起约翰的声音，嗲声嗲气地又是“库珀先生”又是“库珀先生”。
My father promised that when the call finally came, John would apologize for being too hasty and lower the price. I'd have my car before I knew it. One day passed. Two. Three. Each day, I called my father on various transparent pretexts and attempted to find out whether he had heard anything from the salesman. On the fourth day, I steeled myself and asked him outright. "Keep your pants on," grumbled my father. "I said he'd call, didn't I?"
父亲保证，当电话最终打来时，约翰会为自己的仓促道歉并降价。我很快就会有车了。一天过去了。两天。三天。每天，我都以各种透明的借口给父亲打电话，试图查明他是否收到了销售员的消息。第四天，我鼓起勇气直接问他。“把你的裤子提好，”父亲咆哮道，“我说过他会打来的，对吧？”
By the end of the week, however, my pants were sagging. The car had probably been sold. In the meantime, I'd researched the prices at other Toyota dealerships around town and discovered that John's offer was the best of the bunch. And so I called my father in a last-ditch effort to own the car. "Dad," I said, "I've done some comparative pricing." "So?" "I think we should go for the Corolla before it's sold. And if it's a matter of not wanting to pay more than the factory price-- and who can blame you?-- I'd be happy to contribute the extra $200 myself."
然而，到周末结束时，我的裤子都要掉下来了。那辆车可能已经被卖了。与此同时，我查了城里其他丰田经销店的价格，发现约翰的报价确实是其中最好的。所以我最后孤注一掷地给父亲打了电话，想要买下那辆车。“爸爸，”我说，“我做了一些比较定价。” “所以呢？” “我觉得我们应该在卡罗拉卖掉之前去买了。如果是因为不想支付工厂价以上——谁能责怪你呢？——我愿意自己承担那额外的200美元。”
The proposal had about it the pleasing hue of teamwork, and I wished I'd thought of it days ago. "It's not about the $200," shouted my father. "It's a waiting game. He's holding out, so I'll come running back and throw my money at him. If you can't sit tight for a while, if you have to have everything you want right when you want it, you might as well forget the whole damn thing." Before he hung up, he said, "And don't pester me anymore. I'll call you when the car is ready."
这个提议带着一种团队合作的美好色调，我真希望几天前就想到它。“这不是200美元的事，”父亲吼道，“这是一场等待的游戏。他正在坚持，等着我回去跑向他并把钱甩给他。如果你不能耐心等一会，如果你必须在想要时立刻得到你想要的东西，那你最好还是把这该死的车忘了吧。”在挂断电话前，他说：“别再烦我了。车准备好了我会给你打电话。”
The bill arrived after a month of silence. By then, I'd given up on the car, resigned to drive the Fiat until it broke down completely or until I could afford to make payments on a new car, whichever came first. I suspected my father might brood about our day at the dealership, but I wasn't prepared for the extremity of his reaction, if, in fact, the bill was a reaction.
在一个月的沉默后账单寄到了。那时，我已经放弃了那辆车，认命地开着菲亚特直到它彻底报废，或者直到我负担得起新车的车贷，无论哪个先到。我怀疑父亲可能会对我们在经销商那儿的一天怀恨在心，但我还没准备好他那极端反应，如果那张账单确实是一种反应的话。
Whenever I tried to make a connection, the machinery of cause and effect began to break down. Perhaps, in the intervening month, my father had become more offended by my offer to supplement the cost of the car, thinking I'd implied he couldn't afford it, couldn't pull off the deal on his own. Who was I, he must have wondered, to offer him money?
每当我试图把它们联系起来，因果机制就开始崩溃。也许，在那一个月的时间里，我主动提出补充车费的行为让他更加愤怒，认为我暗示他买不起，或者自己无法独立谈成这笔交易。他一定在想，我算什么东西，竟然对他提供金钱？
And yet, even taking into account the full force of my father's volatility, it seemed unlikely that my offer of $200 would result in him suing me for $2 million. As the days wore on, my longing for the car grew dimmer, while my father's, no doubt, deepened-- my plan should have worked, that car should be ours-- thrusting him back to the deprivation he knew as a boy. The salesman's refusal to call must have undermined his notion of how the world worked, how bargains were struck by men like himself, men possessed of wile and nerve.
然而，即使考虑到我父亲那反复无常的全部力量，我提出200美元却导致他控告我200万美元的可能性似乎也不大。随着日子一天天过去，我对车的渴望变得暗淡，而父亲的渴望毫无疑问加深了——我的计划本该奏效，那辆车本该是我们的——这让他回到了他童年所知的匮乏中。销售员拒绝回电一定动摇了他对世界运作方式的认知，对他这样的人——那些拥有诡计和胆量的男人——如何达成交易的认知。
What had happened, or failed to happen, defined his every paternal assurance, his promise that the phone would ring, the salesman buckle, the car become mine. How humiliated he must have been to know that I awaited his call. That he'd ask me to wait must have made it worse. My father's refusal to be in the wrong meant that I'd have to wait forever.
所发生或未发生的事，定义了他所有的父权保证，他保证电话会响，销售员会屈服，车会成为我的。他一定很羞愧，因为他知道我在等着他的电话。他要求我等待一定让事情变得更糟。父亲拒绝认错意味着我将永远等待。
20 years have passed since I opened that bill, and for most of those years, I'd taken it for granted that at some point during our afternoon in West Covina, my father had given the dealer his telephone number. But I've sifted through that trip a dozen times, squinting against the glare of new cars, breathing the icy air of the showroom. And I can't recall my father handing over one of his business cards or filling out a form of any sort. Even if my father had been right after all, the salesman wouldn't have known where to reach him, what number to call.
那张账单寄出已经20年了，在过去的大部分时间里，我一直认为在西科维纳的那个下午的某个时候，父亲给了经销商他的电话号码。但我已经把那次行程回想了十几遍，眯着眼对抗新车的反光，呼吸着陈列室冰冷的空气。我不记得父亲递出过他的名片或填写过任何表格。即使父亲最终是对的，销售员也不会知道去哪儿联系他，打什么号码。
Josh Hamilton reading an excerpt from a story by Bernard Cooper, which first appeared in the LA Weekly and is now part of the book The Bill From My Father.
乔什·汉密尔顿为您朗读伯纳德·库珀故事的摘录，该故事首次出现在《洛杉矶周刊》，现在也是《我父亲的账单》一书的一部分。
Special thanks today to Adrian LeBlanc, [? Karen Thomas, ?] and Jay Allison. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Whenever I send anybody over to record him, he says--
特别感谢今天的阿德里安·勒布朗，[? 凯伦·托马斯 ?] 和杰伊·艾利森。我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。每次我派人去录制他时，他都会说——
You come here and you tape me for your stupid friend's radio show, and then you get the hell out.
你来到这儿录下我为你那个傻朋友的广播节目，然后立刻滚出去。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。